everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm so they're gonna be
continuing our series in the 2014 rapid
Chess Championships if you're not super
familiar with the format they play
Monday Tuesday Wednesday rapid chess and
that is a 15 minutes game per player
they also get a 10 second increment for
each move that they make so the faster
moves they make they can actually get
more time on the clock than the 15
minutes originally allocated to him and
today's match we're gonna be going over
whites gonna be played by Fabiano car
horn in my opinion the second best
player in the world behind magnus
carlsen actually think in a few years
he'll be the top player he has that much
talent so always a fun to watch him play
I've done a lot of commentary on him
before and I think he's a phenomenal
chess player and really really young
his opponents gonna be Viktor ball again
a very very established player as well
so we'll go ahead and get into it why it
starts with poncey four always loved the
aggressive lines and then pawn to g6
actually pick this opening one because
I'm just a big [ __ ] huh car horn fan
but I also just don't see the modern
defense very often from black so I
thought I'd actually do a video since we
saw this defense pawn here to g6 plenty
here to d4 gonna watch just gonna try to
gobble up the center of the board gain
complete control and then Black's gonna
try kind of a hyper modern defense where
he controls the center with his minor
pieces and then only commits his pawns
later in into the game White's also
gonna try to choke his opponent a little
bit as far as gaining a lot of space and
not allowing his opponent to really
counter attacked and the center of the
board we now see pawn here to our Bishop
here to g7 Fink hitting on the King side
getting right to castle very quickly
Knight here it's a c3 pawn here to c6
kind of interesting move but getting
ready to push forward with pawn here to
d7 Bishop to e3 opening up the
possibility for whites actually castle
on the Queen side Blitzen rapid chess
you see in my opinion a lot more
castling on the Queen side it's a lot
more aggressive usually your opponents
are castling on the King side so you can
go ahead and castle on the Queen side
and then throw all your pieces and your
pawns at your opponent on the Kings side
it does extremely well in very fast
chests and longer games for your
opponent has a lot
more time to strategize you just don't
see it as much usually both sides are
always cancelling on the kingside black
now gets his Queen of all to the game
with b6 threatening both this pawn here
on d4 and the pawn here on a b2 so we're
over here to be one not really any other
option on board Knight to f6 pawn here
to h3 wants to make sure that it kind of
stops this Knight here to g4 it is kind
of an awkward move in this particular
opening Castle on the kingside Knight to
f3 getting ready to castle on the
kingside now he has that option he's no
longer going to be castling on the Queen
side although he may have wanted to but
since he was kind of forced to bring his
rook over here to b1 he's not gonna be
doing that in this particular game pawn
here to d5 we kind of look at it black
is kind of cramped in this position so
he has to do something he right now
can't get his knight involved to either
c6 or d7 so he needs to get this pawn
involved d5 does a couple things but one
thing it does is it allows Fabiana
that's actually push forward completely
forget about it and since these pawns
are kind of pointed toward the king side
from black that's really where White's
gonna be focusing a lot of this time
right here and so this does gain some
additional space for white black has to
really be be weary of that so that's
gonna come down here to the newly-minted
outpost here from the pawn here on d5
and then we see a nice little exchange
right here and then that's gonna fall
back here to d2
somewhat of a passive move he could have
always played a little bit more
aggressive with Knight here to g5 still
attacking the pawn here but again this
is completely fine the knight comes back
attacks this pawn and blacks kind of
forced to do something with it so first
place pawn here to a c5 trying to break
up the center of the board again black
strategy with kind of a modern defense
is to control from the diagonals control
with his minor pieces and then kind of
chip away with his pawns only after
White's kind of already tried to
solidify the center of the board
so pawn here to c3 kind of counter
attacking pawns gonna recapture so white
still has both in the center pawns black
has just two Center pawns but they're
both on the
you found not nearly as effective pawn
here to f5 solidifying this pawn here on
e on e4 I think it makes way more sense
to take here on f6 this is called um
pissant does not some made-up move that
I just came up with you can look it up
if you think that move was illegal but
in the particular game I decided to go
with the non opposite move of just pawn
here to a g3 doesn't want his opponent
to come down here to f4 and so again
that kind of stops that right here King
over here to h8 because of this square
here on f7 is kind of pushed forward
it's very aggressive but he does have to
be aware that white can now be
developing with Bishop here to see for
threatening the King so he just doesn't
want to have to worry about that at all
pawn here to h4 white now has the
possibility of not even castling at all
yeah he recognizes that his opponent
it's kind of in a corner and he's gonna
start to push up all of his pieces and
never worry about castling at all pawn
here to h6 trying to stop some of the
threats of white pushing forward a
little bit too much Knight here to see
for getting involved to the action again
it was pretty passed him back here in d2
wasn't doing a whole heck of a lot now
attacking the Queen the Queen comes back
here to d8 Queen to d2 getting it more
involved into the game King to h7 not
doing too much but he does need another
defender possibly on the square here on
h6 rook swinging over here to d1 more of
a centralized square your roofs always
belong behind your pawns and the stern
of the board or in semi open files like
this C file I decided it was more
important to bring his rook behind this
Queen here on D two blocks now I'm gonna
centralize his Queen with Queen to d5
the Knights gonna come back here Knight
to c6 again blacks getting a little bit
of momentum here getting his pieces
involved into the sand of the board
Bishop here to a c4 kind of stops that
the knight back here it's actually
allowing this bishop to develop with
tempo here the Queen is forced to move
white now decides to go ahead and castle
on the Kings side so he said you know I
want my pieces being pinned down too
much I do have some safety although
there's a little bit of air over here in
front of the king but my opponent only
has one night so it's gonna be somewhat
difficult for him to kind of slip in
here also there's a lot of pawns here
stopping that so he thought it was
somewhat safe to go ahead and castle on
the Kings side black decides to go ahead
and exchange off pieces and again any
time you're playing someone at the
caliber or Fabiano I think it is good to
exchange off some of the more powerful
pieces on board now the interesting move
in the game is pawn here to e6 and it
kind of opens up the door for Fabiana to
play a really really good move and
that's Knight here to b5 now yeah this
night here on a3 wasn't doing too much
his knight was on the rim you know an
eye on the rim is grim but he was gonna
be getting involved anyway but the
knight to b5 is just all of a sudden
just detrimental to black we now see
Knight here to c7 threatening both this
pawn and this rook because the bishops
also attacking this pawn here on c6 it's
gonna be very difficult for black to
kind of hold onto that if the knight
comes up here to c7 the route comes to
f7 trying to stop the attack on that
square but Knight here to d6 great
little outpost from this pawn here on e5
it's gonna be somewhat difficult and
tricky for black to kind of get this
night off of this outpost and again it's
attacking this rook here on f7 the rook
is forced to move blacks pretty much in
defense mode this LightSquared Bishop is
not involved into the action and all the
rook over here on a 8 can't do anything
at all the stars for Bishop is kind of
blocked off we see white with a pretty
active game plan right here he has a
very active night here on d6 his lights
for a bishop is much more involved in
his opponent both of his rooks can
easily get involved neither of them are
on defense duties so you know Caruana
definitely has the upper hand in this
particular situation we now have the
rook swing over here to see one again
those open files really want you where
you want your rooks pawn here to a6
Bishop back here to b3 kind of a safer
Square rook to b8 it's not doing too
much but again black just doesn't have a
whole lot of options you definitely
doesn't have anything very aggressive
pawn here to g4 why it's pretty much
saying that
he can go ahead and just blow up the
King side of the board he's not too
worried about his opponents position so
after the pawn takes now we see the
bishop come back here to see two
attacking the square here on e4 this
opens up not only this this F file but
now he can take with his bishop here on
e4 it's very centralized for the light
square bishop so definitely going to be
very good and black just can't hold on
to it anymore so the bishop takes the
risk of swinging over here to c7 trying
to count our attack on the Queen side he
can't do as much on the Queen side cuz
all of his pieces are over on the Queen
side night to ESET or to e8 attacking
both of these pieces the vers gonna have
to move he now bring the back to this
nice little outpost here on f6 now black
decides hey I just don't want to deal
with that anymore and my dark square
bishop wasn't doing a whole heck of a
lot anymore but the pawn takes and all
of a sudden it's a passed pawn and it's
gonna be very difficult for black to
deal with the rest of the game and is
attacking this rook right here it comes
back to f7 and all begin all of a sudden
it's on defense duty once again now the
bishops gonna come here to f4 attacking
this rook but after the rook moves
because again we talked about coming to
b8 didn't do a whole heck of a lot
anyway now the bishop can come to e5 and
in two simple moves all of a sudden this
pawn now has somewhat of a nice outpost
and even if his opponent were to take
here on e5 he would still have his pawn
taking back and has a nice little a dual
pawn action right here instead of his
opponents you know mulligan decided to
play a pretty questionable movie played
knight here two before and I see this
sometimes in the rapid Championships but
some players just don't recognize when
they're under a ton of pressure in this
particular case you know Victor is a ton
of pressure and that's the one
opportunity that he chooses to take his
piece away from the side that's being
under attack so Fabiana is just going to
continue to attack the King side of the
board a pawn here to f3 after it takes
the Kings gonna move up again we're
approaching the end game so getting your
King involved to the action is very very
important you don't want it to just stay
back
it's actually an important piece Knight
here to addy
I've rook swinging back over here to gg1
this is a semi-open file so White's
really controlling again if we look at
it black still has not moved his light
square bishop or his other rook over
here on a8 we now see the risks going to
take here on f6 just didn't not want to
see that pawn which is interesting just
said okay yeah I just don't want to deal
with it so I'm just gonna give up that
material why it's gonna take the Knights
and then black just gave up right now he
just looked at and said okay imma take
back this pawn I'm gonna lose my rook
and that's going to be bad for me so a
pretty interesting game you know Fabio
just found some some very small
advantages towards the middle of the
game and then he was just able to really
get more of his pieces developed and
then Viktor just kind of fell apart at
the end so again in my opinion second
best player in the world kind of proving
that he is definitely one of the
strongest and he's near the very very
top of this tournament I think from what
I've seen on day one that he could go on
to easily win the rapid section of the
the championship so hopefully you guys
enjoy this video hopefully you learned a
little bit and got to see some of the
the younger players shine on the scene
for more coverage make sure you check
out the chess website comm and I'll see
you guys tomorrow for more coverage